unique pointer is basically a fancy
wrapper built around new and delete and
I don't use Dynamic allocations so I
don't need unique pointer
is what you might have said before you
watch this video
part of that is true by default a unique
pointer is just a convenience wrapper
around new and delete
it's referred to as a smart pointer
because it takes care of calling this
delete so you don't have to remember to
unlike with the X pointer the Y pointer
gets deleted automatically
but in this video I'm not here to tell
you about the basics of unique pointer
if you have no idea what a unique
pointer is please see my previous video
on the topic
we write a basic implementation of it in
about 50 lines
and if you already know what a unique
pointer is you don't need to watch that
previous video
I mean unless you want to
in this video we're focusing on unique
pointers lesser-known second template
argument the deleter
when a uni pointer is destroyed it
doesn't just call the built-in delete on
its managed object
it actually just passes its raw pointer
to its deleter
it just so happens that the default
eliter calls the built-in delete
but theoretically you could put pretty
much whatever you want there
let's take a look at a classic example
interoperability with a C library
as much as we love C plus plus there are
times when an existing Library that's
already written in C is a better choice
than rewriting something in C plus
but C doesn't have and probably doesn't
want smart pointers so it's very common
for Library functions written in C to
just malix a memory put something in it
and then return the pointer to you
and oftentimes it's up to you the caller
to free that pointer
because the pointer was allocated using
Malik we need to delete it by using free
we can't use the built-in delete
therefore we also can't just use unique
pointer the way we normally would by
default unique pointer uses delete not
free
so instead let's define our own custom
deleter
we Define a call Operator that the
unique pointer will call when it's
destroyed and instead of calling delete
we call free
just throw your Customs leader class in
the second template argument and you're
done now at the closing curly brace the
Mallet pointer will be freed
you may be wondering why I wrapped free
up into a class that has a call Operator
with the same signature as free it's
actually for efficiency you can directly
pass in the free function like this
instead of using our free deleted class
we could use the decal type of the free
function this decal type is a function
pointer type and we're storing the value
free in that function pointer because
the unique pointer actually stores its
deleter inside of itself this means that
it's storing an extra pointer
so if we go ahead and print out the size
of the unique pointer we see that it
ends up being 16 bytes which is the size
of two pointers
on the other hand when we use our free
deleter class we don't specify the
second argument and it just gets default
constructed but a free deleter instance
doesn't have any state
standard Library implementers are very
smart and they do a neat trick here
because the deleter doesn't have any
state they don't store it so as you can
see the unique boner ends up only being
8 bytes which is the size of just a
pointer this is what allows a unique
pointer to have basically no overhead
compared to a raw pointer because when
you do it this way it's just syntactic
sugar that gets all compiled away
now the free to leader is something that
you might want to use over and over
again so it makes sense to give it a
name but if you find yourself in a
situation where you're only going to use
this deleter once you can go ahead and
just put it directly in the template
argument using a Lambda like this this
tends to make things longer and can
quickly become unreadable so use with
caution
on the other hand if you're using these
unique pointers of free to leaders all
over the place and you find it annoying
to constantly write this out then you
can use an alias we use the using
keyword to introduce the Alias and now
we just have a c friendly unique pointer
that uses free instead of delete
personally I often go one step further
and Define a c plus friendly wrapper
around the C function the wrapper just
calls the underlying C function and
wraps it in a unique pointer doing it
this way there's nothing for the caller
to forget they don't need to remember to
call free they don't need to remember to
wrap the result in a unique pointer and
there's no question about whether they
got back an owning pointer or a
non-owning pointer it's a unique pointer
so they definitely own it
and this pattern doesn't just apply to
Heap allocation functions like new and
Malik anytime you have a resource that
doesn't clean up after itself you can
use a unique pointer with a custom
deleter if a C library gave you a file
handle that was opened with f open you
need to close it with f close you could
use a deleter for that
you could even use it with a custom
allocator
I'm using standard allocator which again
just calls new and delete but fill in
here your favorite stack based or Arena
allocator or whatever here
we use a Lambda to Define our custom
deleter which just calls deallocate
then we just pass that in as the second
template argument and second argument of
the unique pointer
the default allocator is stateless and
doesn't do any work upon construction so
it's most efficient to just construct
one right here
because our deleter is stateless once
again we just have an 8 byte pointer if
your allocator is in stateless then
you're going to need to capture it
somehow in this case I'm capturing it by
reference
in this case the unique pointer needs to
store that reference to that allocator
so it does increase the memory usage
so keep that in mind this is actually a
k Square unique pointer does have
overhead
you can get around this by using a
stateless allocator or by storing it in
a global variable
now to the technical part how do they
actually implement the deleter in unique
pointer we're not going to be looking at
the standard Library implementation it's
basically unreadable
but although this is not by any means a
complete or probably even correct
implementation it does carry all the
main ideas in just a few lines of code
if you want to see the basic
implementation that doesn't even have a
deleter then check out my previous video
where I explained the whole thing
so for this we start out by adding the
deleter template argument
no surprise we create a default delete
class that just calls delete and set
that as the default value for the
template argument unlike the version
that used free on the pointer the
version that uses delete needs to be a
template this is because while it's
possible to free a void pointer it's not
possible to delete a void pointer
okay once we have our deleted type then
we just go down to our private members
and add in a deleter member
then in the destructor and reset and in
other places where you might expect
delete to be called instead we call the
deleter passing in Our member pointer
we do an if check here because although
the built-in delete can handle null
pointer not every deleter can
then there are just a few other things
that need to be changed
we add convenience functions like adding
a getter for the deleter
and then pretty much the only other
thing that needs to change is
Constructors
we added a deleter member so we just
need to make sure that all of our
Constructors initialize it
but keep in mind the most common
convenient and efficient case is this
one when we have a stateless deleter
that does nothing upon Construction
pretty much nothing else needs to change
now we have a fully functioning unique
pointer class that even supports custom
deleters
unfortunately though this implementation
has one fatal flaw which we'll see when
we try to run our example again
when we run our example even with the
stateless allocator we see that our
unique pointer is taking up 16 bytes
instead of eight
because the allocator is stateless we
don't really have anything to store but
for some reason it's still taking up
eight bytes
this is because except for special
exceptions an object must take up at
least one byte so that's one byte for
the deleter eight bytes for the pointer
and it takes at least nine and this
class is eight by the line so it ends up
taking 16 bytes but if you remember
standard unique pointer only took up
eight bytes in this case
so how can we achieve that
if you have the great luxury of working
with C plus 20 or later then you have no
unique address
or if you're on Windows msvc no unique
address
maybe they'll implement it without the
msvc in the future
but with no other changes other than
adding this no unique address we're back
down to eight bytes
the no unique address attribute allows
data members to overlap
in the case of a stateless deleter
allowing it to overlap means it doesn't
take up any memory
so this is a hugely important attribute
to become familiar with it can really
really improve the data compactness and
efficiency of your programs
but remember I said you can only do this
if you have the luxury of using C plus
20.
but standard unique pointer Works in C
plus 11. so that means they're doing
something a little bit trickier
they use what's called The Empty base
object optimization which is a clever
trick involving inheriting from your
deleter
and explaining that would be its own
whole video so comment below if you're
stuck on C plus plus 17 or earlier and
want to hear about it
and last but certainly not least I'd
like to thank Pai for becoming an
exponential tier Patron on patreon
I really appreciate the support and
encouragement and I'm glad you think the
videos are worth it
everyone else don't forget to subscribe
and I'll see you in the next one